President Biden is spending Thanksgiving
in Massachusetts and he used the holiday
as a theme in his remarks today we can
also be thankful the families being
recruited and reunited with loved ones
who have been held hostage for nearly 50
days beginning this morning under a deal
reached by extensive us diplomacy
including numerous calls I've made from
the Oval Office to leaders across the
region he stressed that this would just
be the beginning of the process of
captives being released
the expectation that US citizens would
be freed on Friday proved unfounded but
Biden made no mention of the Palestinian
Women and Children released from Israeli
captivity nor the devastating
Palestinian death toll that's resulted
from the Israeli
War across the us there were once again
protests in Chicago Los Angeles and in
Washington it was clear that the
president statements would not assuage
the anger felt by those here I'm here to
you know
know castigate I guess the US also cuz
we send our tax dollars there also the
US funds this genocide these little peac
meal exchanges are really just for media
points to to keep people calm for a
little bit but I think you see this
movement's Focus like people aren't
losing track of what's important here
and uh we're we're saying free free Gaza
free Palestine in the occupation Biden
did say he has encouraged the Israeli
Prime Minister to focus on reducing the
number of casualties
and it has been widely reported that at
the very least the White House is
concerned by how the destruction in Gaza
and the Palestinian death toll look
especially to younger voters as the
presidential election approaches
specifically White House officials are
bristling at the nickname for the
president being chanted at many of these
rallies genocide Joe shans Al jazer
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer